Apple has already reshaped the culture
with its iPhones personal computers and
tablets now it plans to take its next
act on the road on Friday Apple joined
an already crowded field of companies
when the state of California awarded a
permit to test autonomous vehicles also
known as self-driving cars Apple is not
discussing what its plans are no big
surprise there but its intentions to get
into the self-driving car market have
been known for a long time here to break
down the news is russell brandom a
reporter for The Verge Russell good
morning oh thanks for having me the
latest secret to descend Apple mountain
so is this real is Apple really getting
into the market are they late to the
game where they've just been keeping it
under wraps the whole time they're
definitely a little bit late to the game
i think you know we've seen google and
uber who are currently suing each other
over this uh you know they're they've
been making huge strides but with Apple
you never really know what they're doing
until they announce it on stage so
everyone's kind of still waiting and
seeing how do you think this might
change the whole race for in this game
then I think you know Apple's usual
tactic is not to be the first they want
to be the best I mean we saw this with
the iphone it wasn't the first
smartphone but you know very quickly
everyone forgot about the ones that came
before so I think that's probably what
they're doing but there's also still a
lot of questions about is it gonna be
hardware or software some of the rumors
say it's just software I'm personally a
little skeptical i think if they're
gonna do it they want to build their own
car and the you know their famous
designer Jony ive who's you know sort of
the artists behind the iphone has
reportedly always wanted to build a car
it's kind of his dream as an industrial
man or so i don't think they're going to
tell him know what's interesting to me
is when we talk about who's dominating
the race for self-driving cars you say
uber you say Google we're not talking
about Apple none of those are car
companies in the traditional sense of
the word where is Detroit in in this
landscape so I mean they're making big
moves to GM we saw a big announcement
they hired a lot of people they're
building a whole Michigan hob with 1,100
jobs it's yeah yeah absolutely and the
governor sort of passed these new laws
which is similar to what we saw in
California before where they can test on
public roads and I think that's
particularly interesting because a lot
of the places we've seen this test
did are you know it's California it's
Arizona it's Texas a lot of clear States
not getting a lot of snow not getting a
lot of have you read that yeah how far
away are we from this do you think well
so it depends so right now you can buy a
car that's pretty good at highway
driving where it'll stay in the lane
it'll keep a virg speed and then if it
sees a car in front of it it'll slow
down so you can basically take your
hands off the wheel for highway driving
although if something happens you better
be ready to take over yeah the question
is okay now we're in traffic now it's
snowing now it's you know you've got a
stoplight you want to left turn how does
it manage that we're not as good at that
yet but you know it's tricky to set it
yeah in terms of safety concerns though
every couple months were treated to some
horrible story about a crash you think
the safety is going to catch up with the
technology in relatively short order I
don't know I think generally people say
they're not gonna let these on the road
unless it's safer right and right now
they're better at breaking if you see
something in front of you and just yeah
oh my god I gotta slam on the brakes a
computer can break faster than a person
who can write the question is does he
see everything that it needs to see is
it gonna yeah and I mean we saw this
with there was a Tesla crash that I
believe was fatal a while ago where the
car had come across the road and it was
a white tractor-trailer it just didn't
recognize his car we are living in a
brave new world it's tricky for your
time my buddy you